hello everyone i am student of the
indian institute of technology delhi
and this is my presentation for our
project titled identification and
imaging of potential vaccine targets for
the sar cov 2 spike protein
using the machine learning and
bioinformatics tools this was a
collaboration between me
and tavisha and was completed under the
mentorship
of dr mohit mazumdar and dr ilya vrotsky
of the pine biotech laboratories
for the past two years the world is
facing and all sort of the corvit-19
outbreak caused by the novel coronavirus
the
cov2 there is an urgent need for
immunological study to understand
this virus new virus and to develop ways
to control its spread
and our aim in this project is to gain
insights for the vaccine design against
sarcoid ii by considering
the genetic similarities between source
cov2 sars saving marsuov
and these targeted ancient sites have
potential benefit for protection against
the novel virus
now like sarcoid mercury with the recent
source here we do belongs to the
beta-corona virus genius
hence we know that studying the sarcopen
mars uv could be a milestone
for sarcoidological study now in our
study we have focused particularly on
the epitopes in this structural protein
due to their dominant and long-lasting
immune response that was previously
reported against the source cov
this is a detailed overview of the
procedures that we have followed well
followed by us
now let us look at these steps in a
little bit more detail
now firstly we conduct a phylogenetic
analysis of the sar cov mars cov and
starts your video to find genomic
similarities and differences uh we run
a quasi-species virus pipeline with the
faster files of the sarcomeres our co2
amino acid sequences of the spike
protein that which we obtained from the
ncbi protein dataset
and here we have the show shared a
screenshot of the pipeline that movement
next is the acquisition of the epidural
data this we obtained from the naid
virus pathogen analysis and database
analysis resource that is fiber
we searched for immune epitopes under
the coronary artery taxon
and the results were filtered to give
experimentally determined epitopes
of the spine glycogen beta chronic virus
for the human host with at least one
positive assay each for the b cell
t cell and mhcs type assets now
these the filters would have resulted in
518 epidurals and we down to them in the
form of an excel file
here the first table shows the filtering
criteria of corresponding to the more so
we derived revitos in the viper
and the second table shows the filter
criteria the corresponding
uh number of sar cov derived epidurals
that again
obtained from the viper database this
step is running the ebitda conservancy
analysis here
the excel files of uh that we obtained
of the epitopes have to be reconstructed
there to be filtered for different types
of essays
and converted into a faster file and
then uh
uploaded to this iedb conservancy
analysis resource which is shown here
the epidurals with an aligned with this
sar cov2 spike protein
reference amino acid now this step is
the epidural clustering
here uh the the all the the output that
we obtained in the previous step was
filter to obtain laptop sequences
with minimum sequence identity threshold
to be
70 percent and this was performed using
the iadb
ebitda cluster analysis resource which
is a tool
that groups the clusters based on
sequence identity
here it was 70 percent as i mentioned
lastly
we image the sequences of the epitopes
onto the sars service by glycoprotein
and all the epitopes are matched into
the three separate sars cov expired
protein mod models and finally our
results and this is a brief
overview of the results that we obtained
and we'll discuss these results in
detail
the first result is that the spike
glycoproteins of sar cov2 is genetically
similar to the sar cellular but not to
the mars cov
based on full length genome and
phenogenetic analysis
performed in relation to the spike
glycoprotein
and this figure here shows this
phylogenetic analysis that confirms the
deviation of the mars cov
from the sar series or civility in the
epitome analysis
uh earlier we we showed that this very
low genetic similarity
between uh sars uv and marsupial on the
other hand when we replace the mars cov
with source theory we find that
uh there we classified them into two
different acids the t cell assays
and then positive mhc binding acids we
obtained
about 362 t cell assays out of the 61
epitope sequences were identical for
cersei v2 which have been
shown in this table given
and this shows the 33 epitopes of the of
identical epithet of the b
cell assays
and next we have the epitope clustering
result
when we perform the t cell epidural
clustering 61 isis that we
61 epitopes that we obtained earlier got
diverted into 25 different cluster
groups
and when b cell epitope clustering was
performed the 33 identical epitopes
earlier were diverted into 22 different
cluster groups
and we can see this result in the table
here
with this table here shows the t cell
electrodes and this shows the cluster of
the b-cell epitopes
finally we map these clustered as well
as the singleton epitopes into one spike
glycoprotein
from the protein database pdb and 6vxx
was the spike like a body that was
chosen for mapping and when we
mapped all this epidural we found that
some of the epitopes are actually
located quite close to the receptor
binding domain
and this table here it shows the cov
derived b cell and mhc binding epidurals
that were located close to the
rbd and which would total four epidurals
now this shows the source uv derived mnc
binding epidurals
mapped onto the spinal cord crystal and
here these are three views
the front side and top as we can see the
blue regions of the epidural located
near the rbt and the green regions are
located inside the spy glycoprotein
this is for the t cell epitopes mapped
onto the spike glycogen crystal again
the green regions here show all those
which are
all those which are present inside the
spike glyphosate
and we have three different views side
top and front view
and finally this is this d cell epic
this is the b cell
derived dividers that have mapped onto
the cluster model and again there are
three views
front side and top the red region shows
the epitope that is inside and the blue
region shows those near the rvd
these are the references that we
consulted our major source of
inspiration was the preliminary
identification and potential vaccine
targets of the kovind 19th corona virus
rc video based on sar cov meteorological
studies
conducted by ahmed khalil and matthew
thank you very much